[Musik]
auch lady rempelt kann wegen co wird
natürlich nicht richtig auftreten
die drag queen musste sich auf
online-videos und einen podcast verlegen
doch das bremst den elan der rothaarigen
schottischen nationalisten kein bisschen
die kunstfigur brennt in ihrem metier
eher unüblich für politik so wie ihr
schöpfer christopher kleineren ein
studierter jurist als sich entschied
eine drag künstlerin zu werden fragte
ich mich was ich zu dieser kunstform
beitragen könne
viele haben einen hintergrund im theater
kostümdesign oder mega ich brachte jura
und politik in den dreck ganz ohne
berührungsängste macht die queen des
politischen dreck werbung für die
eigentliche königin schottlands
regierungschefin nicolas töten lady
rempelt hat nicolas deutschen noch nicht
getroffen aber das würde sie wirklich
gerne ich glaube nicola würde sie mögen
sie haben viele gemeinsamkeiten
auch christopher ist ein glühender
anhänger der unabhängigkeit schottlands
er empfindet seine heimat als sehr viel
liberaler und progressiver als england
der schotten wählen bei den britischen
wahlen für das parlament in westminster
und bekommen die regierung die wir haben
wollen
das ist einfach ein demokratisches
defizit in der britischen verfassung in
den wahlen zum schottischen parlament
allerdings bekommen die schotten was sie
wollen
alle 129 sitze in etting bader werden
neu vergeben und es gilt als sicher dass
nicolas deutschen das land weitere fünf
jahre führen wird sollte ihre partei
eine absolute mehrheit bekommen dann
würde sie erst recht gas geben für die
unabhängigkeit
eine stimme für die snp ist erstmal eine
stimme für eine erfahrene führung die
uns gut durch die pandemie punkt danach
wird sie den schotten die möglichkeit
geben für die unabhängigkeit zu stimmen
weg von london weg von boris johnson weg
vom brh exit und wieder rein in die eu
davon träumen viele schotten fast das
gesamte letzte jahr hatten die
befürworter der unabhängigkeit die nase
vorn
unter dem eindruck des großen nationalen
in verfolgt überlegen jetzt so manche ob
die union mit england nicht doch ihre
vorteile hat wie kompliziert die
trennung sein könnte zeigt auch die u
boot basis and fairs lane vier u-boote
bestückt mit nuklear raketen haben etwa
10.000 jobs hierher gebracht wenn es um
die unabhängigkeit geht sind die bürger
hier hin und hergerissen nicht so morris
corrie er ist wird er an der britischen
armee und konservativer kandidat des
wahlkreises das gespenst der
unabhängigkeit hängt immer überaus aber
sollten wir noch mal ein referendum
bekommen glaube ich dass die anhänger
des königreichs gewinnen werden
die leute sind doch überwiegend
vernünftig natürlich würde die
unabhängigkeit bedeuten dass die
engländer die eu wurde abziehen müssten
ein graus für diese sind das richtige
friedens camp nicht dass an der
landstraße diesem bruchbuden das hier
ist das peace kennen die stadt unsere
wertvollen u-boot experten
unsere familie arbeiter aldi die diesen
ort am laufen halten
das entlockt willemin in ihrer bruchbude
nur ein trockenes kichern
seit drei jahren lebt die gebürtige
holländerin im peace camp zu dessen
hochzeiten war sie eine von 40
friedensaktivistinnen momentan halten es
hier nur zwei aus
[Musik]
wir verbrennen unentwegt holz aber es
ist immer noch sehr kalt willemin hofft
auf die unabhängigkeit weil sie gegen
den br- exit ist und weil die
atom-u-boote dann aus schottland
verschwinden würden es sind mit
sicherheit so einige russische raketen
auf uns gerichtet aber was die leute
nicht kapieren es dass wenn eine von
denen einschlägt und dazu gibt es
berechnungen dann ist der gesamte
zentral gürtel schottlands vergangenheit
liegt 65 kilometer östlich von hier
patrick harvie ist auf kampagne der
spitzenkandidat der schottischen grünen
ist in der nähe der atom basis
aufgewachsen angst habe ihm das als kind
gemacht sagt er
und das ist in einer klimakrise kein
geld für massenvernichtungswaffen gebe
die grünen sind bei diesen wahlen
königinnen macher wie nicolas surgeons
schottische nationalpartei finden sie
der exit habe alles verändert es müsse
noch ein unabhängigkeitsreferendum geben
je jünger die schotten desto eher sieht
sie das auch so ich habe mich noch nicht
entschieden haben
ich mag sie hat in der pandemie gut
regiert aber ich bin kein großer fan der
unabhängigkeit
ich glaube wir sind gemeinsam besser
dran
wir haben in vielen kriegen gemeinsam
gekämpft viel gemeinsam erlebt so soll
es bleiben
hoffentlich sind wir bald unabhängig und
wenn nächstes mal die grünen gewählt
würden und schottland tritt wieder in
die eu ein
das wäre der hit die grünen werden ihr
ergebnis wohl auf 9 prozent der sitze
verdoppeln
es wird erwartet dass sie den
unabhängigkeit parteien die mehrheit
verschaffen
wenn die britische regierung unsere
mehrheit für die unabhängigkeit weiter
ignoriert und sich darauf versteift den
schotten zu sagen ihr dürft nicht selbst
entscheiden
dann werden sie viele unentschiedene zur
unabhängigkeit drängen
denn die sehen darin nichts als
herablassung
bislang weigert sich boris johnson
kategorisch den schotten dieses
referendum zu gewähren
für samstag werden die ergebnisse der
parlamentswahlen erwartet sollten die
schotten mit ihnen die klare botschaft
aussenden dass sie noch einmal abstimmen
wollen
dann braucht boris johnson einen guten
plan
[Musik]